-
CHIEF OF THE UNITED STATES
SPACE FORCE.
FIRST, HERE'S MY TAKE.
IT'S A FAMOUS SAYING THAT NO
MILITARY PLAN SURVIVES ITS
FIRST CONTACT WITH THE ENEMY.
THE GREATEST TERRORISTS ON WAR,
THE RUSSIAN GENERAL, OFTEN
EXPLAINS THAT STRATEGY MUST BE
DYNAMIC.
CONSTANTLY CHANGING AND
REJUVENATING ITSELF.
HE WROTE THAT SOME GENERALS
CONSIDER ONLY UNILATERAL ACTION
WHEREAS WERE CONSISTS OF A
CONTINUOUS INTERACTION OF
OPPOSITES.
THE WEST NEEDS TO TAKE THE
LESSONS TO HEART IN THIS
STRUGGLE WITH RUSSIA AND
ADJUSTED STRATEGY.
WHICH IS CURRENTLY IN DANGER OF
FAILURE.
THE CORE OF THE WEST STRATEGY
HAS BEEN TWO-PRONGED.
TO PROVIDE UKRAINE WITH ARMS,
TURNING, AND MONEY INTO IMPOSE
MASSIVE SANCTIONS ON RUSSIA.
THAT BASIC IDEA STILL MAKES
SENSE, BUT THE BALANCE NEEDS TO
CHANGE.
IT IS NOT CLEAR THAT THE
ECONOMIC WAR AGAINST RUSSIA IS
NOT WORKING NEARLY AS WELL AS
PEOPLE THOUGHT IT WOULD.
PUTIN CARES LESS ABOUT THESE
SANCTIONS DUE TO THE RUSSIAN
PEOPLE VENDETTAS BUT WHAT THEY
DO TO THE RUSSIAN STATE.
THANKS TO RISING ENERGY PRICES,
BLOOMBERG PROJECTS THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT WILL MAKE
CONSIDERABLY MORE OIL AND GAS
BANDED BEFORE THE WAR.
AROUND 285 BILLION 2022, KIM
PAIRED 236 BILLION IN 21.
MEANWHILE, EUROPE IS FACING ITS
WORST ENERGY CRISIS IN 50 YEARS.
>> THE BASIC PROBLEM WITH THE
ECONOMIC WAR AGAINST RUSSIA, AS
I'VE ARGUED BEFORE, IS THAT IT
IS TO FIRST BECAUSE IT CANNOT
SANCTION ALL OF RUSSIAN ENERGY.
THE RUSSIAN ECONOMY IS
FUNDAMENTALLY AND ENERGY
ECONOMY.
REVENUES FROM OIL AND GAS ALONE
MAKE ALMOST HALF OF THE
GOVERNMENT'S BUDGET.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE SOLUTION
WOULD NOT BE FOR THE WEST TO
STOP BUYING RUSSIAN ENERGY
ALTOGETHER, BECAUSE WITH LESS
SUPPLY ON THE ROADS MARKET, IT
WILL DRIVE PRICES HIGHER.
HAVING DEVELOPED A DANGEROUS
DEPENDENCE ON RUSSIA'S ENERGY
OVER THE LAST TWO DECADES,
EUROPE CANNOT QUICKLY CHANGE
THAT WITHOUT PLUNGING INTO A
DEEP AND PROTRACTED RECESSION.
LOOK AT WHAT IS ALREADY
HAPPENING ON THE CONFIDENCE TO
NATURAL GAS PRICES ARE 70%
HIGHER THAN THEY WERE AT THE
BEGINNING OF LAST YEAR.
I'M JULY LEVANT, THE PIPELINE
THROUGH IS GERMANY GETS MOST OF
ITS RUSSIAN GAS IS SCHEDULED TO
CLOSE FOR MAINTENANCE.
IT IS POSSIBLE THAT PUTIN WILL
DECIDE TO PUNISH THE WEST AND
GERMANY BY NOT LETTING IT
REOPEN.
IF SO, GERMANY, EUROPE'S
LARGEST ECONOMY, WILL ALMOST
CERTAINLY GO INTO A RECESSION.
PUTIN'S STRATEGY APPEARS TO BE
IMPOSE COSTS ON THE WEST IN
PLAY FOR TIME ASSUMING THAT
CRACKS IN THE COALITION AGAINST
HIM WILL GROW AS THE ECONOMIC
PAIN IN THESE COUNTRIES GROWS.
WESTERN COUNTRIES ARE STILL
WATCHING THIS CHALLENGE AS A
PARAMOUNT PRIORITY.
VIOLENCE HAS A HUGE GAS FIELD,
IT'S ACTUALLY SLOWING DOWN
PRODUCTION.
GERMANY STILL REVERSE ITS SELF
DEFEATING PHASE OUT OF NUCLEAR
ENERGY.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
MAKING IT HARDER TO FINANCE
LONG TERM INVESTMENTS AND GAS
AND OIL.
IT ALSO CAN'T SEEM TO FIND A
WAY TO RESTORE THE IRAN NUCLEAR
DEAL, A MOVE THAT WOULD BRING
ENORMOUS INFLUX OF NEW OIL
SUPPLIES ON OIL MARKET AND
ALMOST CERTAINLY STABILIZED THE
PRICE.
I UNDERSTAND THERE ARE VALID
OBJECTIONS AND CONCERNS ALL
THESE POLICIES.
THE PRIORITY HAS TO BE TO
DEFEAT VLADIMIR PUTIN.
MEANWHILE, PUTIN'S REAL
VULNERABILITIES ARE IN THE
MILITARY FRONT, WITH THE
RUSSIAN ARMY HAS EXPANDED ITS
CONTROL OF THE DONBAS REGION OF
UKRAINE.
AT GREAT COST.
THOUSANDS OF RUSSIAN SOLDIERS
HAVE DIED AND SUPPLIES ARE
DWINDLING AND MOST IMPORTANTLY,
THEY'RE FINDING A VERY TOUGH TO
GET RECRUITS.
THE CONGRESS REPORT OF THE
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT IS HAVING A
HARD TIME FILLING THE RANKS AND
IS OFFERING THE RECORDS TRIPLE
MEDIAN WAGE.
RUSSIA IS SUFFERING HEAVY
LOSSES OF MILITARY EQUIPMENT
THAT WILL BE DIFFICULT TO
REPLACE, ESPECIALLY AS IT
REQUIRES FISCAL TECHNOLOGY.
ALMOST ALL OF WHICH ARE USED TO
IMPORT THE WEST AND ALLIES.
RECENTLY, SECRETARY OF COMMERCE
REVEALED THAT CAPTURED RUSSIAN
EQUIPMENT WAS FOUND TO CONTAIN
COMPUTER CHIPS OUT OF
REFRIGERATORS AND DISHWASHERS.
QUESTION LEADERSHIP DENIES THAT
ECONOMIC SANCTIONS SIMPLY WILL
NOT WORK IN TIME FOR IN THE MIX
INCENSE.
I SHOULD TRY TO INCREASE AS
MUCH OF THE SUPPLY OF ENERGY
WORLDWIDE AS THEY CAN, BUT ALSO
DIALED BACK THOSE SANCTIONS
THAT ARE CAUSING MORE PAIN TO
THE WEST INTO RUSSIA.
MEANWHILE, THEY SHOULD AMP UP
MILITARY SUPPORT TO UKRAINE
EARLY ON THE SIDE OF TAKING
MORE RISKS.
FREEING OUT THE BLACK HEAD
AROUND ODESSA, FOR EXAMPLE,
WOULD BE A HUGE ECONOMIC WOUND
FOR UKRAINE IN SHADOWING
SYMBOLIC DEFEAT FOR RUSSIA.
WINTER IS COMING.
HOMES IN EUROPE MIGHT NOT HAVE
ENOUGH HEAT.
TROOPS ON UKRAINE WILL F